along the way working together your
films became visually more beautiful was
this because you were changing Styles
was it because you had more money did
you make the decision to make them more
visually beautiful job and something
wicked because the Regina just died and
I went by the Bajaj young me on the
module shirt that's a permanent boy to
show my million as I think one thing I
would say is that this earlier thumb
that we made they are very sad and very
melancholic kind of movies so that's a
reason why visually they were probably
less colorful so to speak I would like
to think that as black and white colored
films or colored black and white films
however you want to look at it that's
the way I think of them I think these
are movies that fundamentally are
melancholic so we feel like no visually
that's the way we wanted to take care of
it made by the Dean Toby Young say one
is easy way to put on that one
gwanggaeto league a measured yeah and
what happened later is that the story
changed that each time ho Shia and
director ho made a movie each time was a
different experience so that allowed me
to experience with the lights with the
visual atmosphere with the visual
expression the visual look of the movie
so after that once the stories are to
change there was more room for me to
play around visually yes when you're
working together howdy
how does it go does
does mr. Howe tell you a feeling that he
wants does he say oh I want these colors
does does he what exactly what does he
tell you and what do you say to him or
and what do you suggest and what I mean
how do you interact when you're doing it
she said oh dr. Chiba Mihrimah Chiba in
town you don't they hung me often jinto
touch so Hahnemann topit I don't need
someone sing who what the material Jade
are you fairly single you bro me
- Aloha Aloha Mia so it emits ago a
challenge emoji - ah what do is Yong
Yong Yong Yong Hwa meant and she and I
were young again
Natalya roads going to answer that even
hey Zhang hua - UNC Wong and a food ETSU
gun and they don't Ching Wong the young
you are young you Italian just what the
agency Ching no it's a member there was
telling me about a patient who I know
that paper at the pianos oak and the
more each anchor should show us this is
the only Quang to me ampules yet no
table of aniseed ents they are young Tom
Schaad sound Baba
yes I want to say that often time
director who would not use a script or
if he did it's a piece of paper with a
few sentences like just a scribbled on
the page and Mark Lee was making a joke
saying that even today you can see that
often time we'd really understand what
he's saying so he imagined I have to
communicate with him every day and sort
of confusion I must have had and you
said that you know oftentimes director
Howe would just tell me the feeling and
the way that he described things even
though it's simple but often it's very
visual
it gives me a picture of what the film's
supposed to look like and there are also
occasions when he would point out
specific color the often time the
instruction were very simple so for
example on flowers of Shanghai you know
we shot movie for a long time for a
period of several years but we plenty
for a period of several years but the
one direction that he gave me the only
really direction he gave me was
saying that he wanted to get the feeling
the feel for the clothing of the actors
of the characters and he wanted visually
this to look like an oil painting so
that was our guiding operating principle
and that allow me to make the movie but
often time I think I would just try to
imagine what director home means or the
kind of world he's imagining and
picturing that's kind of my job and what
I do
does director Howe ever say no sir your
words
it's a map a bunch of Taba doctor also a
pilot type young fuko-chan wanna know
God's rules yes this is Emma
I remember the things I was a Shanghai
where there was one time where we have
this agreement when I was shooting
director Hawk came to me and said that
this is too beautiful this is too
beautiful what you're doing it's not
realistic so he actually tried to reduce
the light eternal lights off that floor
was really sunny and so need you ha you
want a gun yes the evil robots
initiation and logic analyzer in Kapaa
de so I told him that because there the
this idea of the film needing to look
like an oil painting that was the only
direction he gave me over that
three-year period so I told him actually
that if you want this to look realistic
I mean in terms of the sort of things
are going asked him for at the same time
in terms of the feeling for the clothing
visually this needing to look like an
oil painting this is impossible what
you're asking Diane sure was for yo soy
soy it's truly the gwang-pil so when
they're talking Diane pantry qualities
horrid high tiers or a llamado qionghua
dishes because at the time the director
ho just thought like it was just too
beautiful the lights were too beautiful
so why it did was visually end up doing
this thing that we call beautified
realism or heightened realism pretty
realism and this kind of beautified
glorified realism is basically what we
end up adapting and also for our
subsequent films